je suis fier j'ai failli j'ai failli
être en retard elle ne voit pas ce que
je suis venu en de but en deux non pas
qu en france on n'a pas de pétrole mais
on a des idées
alors j'ai troqué ma deux shows contre
une de voeux on avait peut-être vu
devant le studio c'est une deux blancs
tachés de roue alors quand on dit qu'est
ce que vous avez comme voitures jugées
une devait alors les gens sont surpris
parce qu'ils s'attendent à le voir il en
rolls roce l'artiste
alors quand ils voient arriver en 2 me
ils sont déçus alors les réflexions des
gens tiens là la paire de boeufs du père
de l'eau sur mon passage les quolibets
les mamans à leurs petits enfants
s'il est mieux qu'ils pas cacher vos
rouge thèmes liés alors les enfants
sauve qui peut parce qu'ils te veux ça
pose des problèmes
exemple un fil rouge une deux shows
s'arrête pas le but et bah forcément le
roux ça les excite alary fonce et quand
sévère
alors pour faire un par diane de mac et
routes ça fait pop
cet après midi sur mon passage est un
irresponsable qui a créé suivent elles
peuvent appeler un tas tension celui
avec des pancartes oui et marc moreau
rage pour corser le tout il y avait une
affiche de la vache qui rit
on ne sait pas ce qui se passe dans la
tête des voeux est-ce qu'ils ont cru que
la vache foot et 2 ils ont foncé dans
talons tête baissée et pour retirer le
veut parce qu'un peuple c'est comme un
bulldozer ça enfonce tout est encore un
bulldozer vous pouvez l'arrêter
vous n'avez qu'à couper l'arrivée
d'essence ya coupé mets un boeuf qu'est
ce que voulait couper est lui déjà